[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and one time athlete
although not of the professional kind
for that as my co-host we got gary
o'reilly gary hey neil all right man uh
former pro soccer player
footballer as i think they call him over
yes across the pond always good to have
you there as my co-host and of course
chuck nice yes someone who has actually
seen a pro soccer game
so for this episode of sports edition uh
it's it's a new format
really and it's called
uh gary what are we calling it athletes
ask neil yes that's what it's called so
what what have you cooked up here gary
well i think what we've done is we've
we've gone and found some super elite
world famous athletes and said hey
why don't you ask neil a question
and they went
really i get that chance i get the
opportunity to ask neil a question yeah
i love it what do you got what's on your
mind and so this is
this is a little taster of what we're
hoping to bring forward in the future
yeah it's good let's see how this how
this how this goes down and if i can't
answer the question that means this this
format has failed
chuck and i'll
i'm looking at the list here oh my gosh
we got uh eli manning we got lindsey
vonn jerry rice tony gonzalez oh my god
i'm looking forward to this okay this is
actual uh recordings of them asking me
questions i i love it
i love it and and uh we have three
segments
and did you theme the segments gary
uh
maybe
okay but it's a surprise so you'll have
to figure it out
yeah something like that all right all
right well then let's who's up first who
do you have let's introduce each athlete
as they come first up tony gonzalez
friend of the show he's a former nfl
titan i've been on his podcast
he's a lucky man so
and i mean a lot of people in the sport
consider him to be one of the best ever
in that position particular position 14
times yeah 14 times pro bowler
and he probably owns more records than
tamil and motown
because he just played and played and
played and played so just to be clear a
pro bowler is the football equivalent of
in baseball you'd be an all-star right
that's right absolutely yeah okay
yeah so all right let's let's line tony
up and
see if he is a science curious athlete
let's do this i'm obsessed with quantum
physics and certain molecules or neurons
or whatever you want to call it and or
protons right and and they'll you look
away and they'll be in a different place
and um where do you think
that
quark or whatever where does it go
when i look away and it's now in a
different place where did it go
oh he's got a magic question whoa
that's like how did you make the coin
disappear from your hand like this
wow that was amazing wait wait wait wait
chuck you're you're accusing an entire
branch of physics of being just a cheat
music magician that's that
you just insulted
century
physics quantum physics hogwarts what's
the note
well actually einstein ruminated on this
and when he started uncovering how
quantum physics actually works which is
probabilistically rather than
deterministic
right he's famously said no i don't
believe this
god doesn't play dice with the universe
oh wow what a great what a wow yeah
so so and he and he mentioned god a few
more times and then niels bohr
another fellow physicist of the day said
einstein would you stop telling god what
to do
that's a funny exchange that's pretty
cool yeah
so uh yeah quantum physics however
uncomfortable it makes people feel
uh first of all the universe has no
obligation to make sense to us
to any of us
it's under no obligation at all this
just make that your first sort of point
of reference in trying to decode the
operations of nature second
quantum physics what he's referring to
is the the observer effect all right
where you want to observe a particle
and the act of observing it has a change
state and then it's somewhere else doing
something else and if you're not looking
at it it's doing something that you
don't you can't see
but you know it's doing it but how do
you know it's doing it if you can't see
it so all the refrigerator light it's
refrigerant it's refrigerator light
i tweeted about the refrigerator light
in a list of unsolved problems in the
universe i should read i should repost
that i just said you know the art the
origin of the universe the origin of
life
and what is dark matter and
does the refrigerator light go out yeah
people people got all got got into
battles over that people even mounted
their cell phone cameras in the
refrigerator
to to film it and just say see
it does happen
so i was like what's interesting neil
when einstein references god
you spin it round another way and look
at it
he's this thing being there and not
being there is about faith
that you have faith in the fact that
this is true
i don't know if that would be the case
though because what we're really looking
at is the probability or the likelihood
of something happening as opposed to
just believing that it might happen or
not right and here's what's interesting
interesting thing about quantum
mechanics even though everything is
statistical essentially everything is a
statistical statement about what will
happen
that implies well you don't really know
well
the statistics that we compile for it
are precise
right this will happen exactly this
number of times out of this many trials
okay will it happen on this particular
trial i don't know
will on the next i don't know but the
ensemble trials it will happen with high
precision so in a sense we are certain
about our uncertainties um
wow
deal with it okay
okay yeah so so here here's how here's
how it goes uh we are macroscopic
objects we are human beings and if i say
chuck i enter a darken room and i say
chuck where are you
and i can't see you is that a is that a
black joke
no
what what the hell just happened okay
sorry okay i'm in a snow bank and
chuck why everything gotta be black to
black joke to you i told you because i
live in america because you live in
america
so
all right so i'm in a room it's dark i
don't know where you are so i turn on
the lights and then i see you right okay
so how do i end up seeing you because
the light came from the bulb or whatever
went to your skin reflected off your
skin and went to my eyeball and i say
that's where chuck is
all right
now you're a big macroscopic object if i
start making you littler and littler and
littler
then the energy of the light that hits
you right becomes significant compared
to who and what you are getting
illuminated right so if i make you small
enough to be the size of a particle
right let's say oh particle where are
you
and then i turn on the lights
the light beam the photons of light will
hit the particle and kick it somewhere
else
right
so the very act of observing the
particle has nothing to do with
consciousness or your brain it has to do
with shining light on it right so that i
can identify where it is and the very
act of doing so kicks it out of that
place and sends it somewhere else
do i know where else actually no
because i have to put on another light
and figure out where that point is and
by the time i do that it jumps to
another state
so all we can do is describe the
probability
of where it is at any given time
and so
so yeah i mean it's it's a striking
phenomenon that freaked us all out our
my my
century-old brethren trying to figure
this out coming out of the classical era
of physics
where yeah so you push a particle it
moves it's there it's where you expect
it to be when you expect it to be there
and all that had to get tossed out the
window
so where does it go i have no idea but i
can answer you
statistically
where
where it likely went after i did it and
that's the best i can do that's the best
the universe can do and einstein in fact
god does play dice with the universe
a new pair of shoes
[Laughter]
so we found a way to have deeper thought
because of science
but we found a way to have what deeper
thought so the way that we look at this
quantum mechanics quantum physics has
meant that we need to think in a deeper
different way i would say different i
don't want to call it deeper it's all
deep but we definitely have to think
differently and
and that was hard for many people some
people just died
fighting and by the way here's einstein
not believing that the universe is
actually statistical yet he made major
contributions to quantum physics in the
1920s and and beyond
we're approaching the centennial decade
of the discovery of quantum physics
which by the way
would become the foundation of the
entire world of information technology
there is no creation storage and
retrieval of information
without a deep understanding and
exploitation of the rules of quantum
physics
there you go not just me deep totally
deep
wait so gary did i just blow an entire
segment answering only one question
maybe um but that's good now we can get
two shows out of this
all right when we come back i'm told
gary has even more questions for me from
other
professional athletes who are at the top
of their game when star talk sports
edition
athletes ask neil
continues
we're back star talk sports edition a
new feature we're testing called
athletes ask
neil and and chuck and gary you all went
out there and got
marquee athletes to ask me stuff
maybe these are questions about the
universe that have plagued them since
childhood perhaps
but i look forward to this so who do we
have up next all right so the next
player is a former major league baseball
player with the mets the dodgers and the
blue jays a golden glove winner hit the
most home runs in one game which was
four hit most home runs in three
consecutive games
seven
okay and
there's a another athlete who really
wants to know something about the cosmos
and his name is sean green john green
bring it on all right hey neil are there
any promising propulsion and energy
storage technologies that can help us go
beyond our nearest neighbors and explore
other solar systems and uh if so
how far away are we from doing this
why do they sound so young is that
because i'm just an old fart and
professional athletes are like well
they're 20 how do we how do you say this
not to upset you yeah
just just think of it like this just
think of it like this
they don't have a lot of 50 year old pro
athletes that's okay is that what it is
yeah yeah unless they're bowlers or
somebody exactly yeah all right nicely
done chuck okay
so
that's an age-old problem we're still
grappling with okay our rockets today
use combinations of chemicals
that are what we call exothermic whereas
you bring them together
energy gets released when the atoms and
molecules combine exothermic if it
absorbs energy it's endothermic
and gary probably knows about this
because you have
ice packs and heat packs
that you can just crack oh you know you
you crumble it how does it work it's a
package right sealed back
and
one variety
you you you smack it to get down it
makes the the molecules merge and it
generates heat another one the molecules
merge and they absorb heat and then
it'll feel cold to you you you probably
use both of those in your day yeah right
yep absolutely so yeah that's a that's a
really easy analogy to
to get in your mind so yeah thank you
for that yeah so with rockets we have
exothermic reactions so imagine gary
doing that and then exhaust comes out
the side
all right so so much energy is produced
that your heat pack
enters orbit okay so we're very clever
about our chemistry we find the the
atoms that when you combine are highly
exothermic
among them is the water molecule i don't
know if you knew this did you guys know
this
okay do you remember the space shuttle
way back when we used to have our own
space program in the united states um we
had the space shuttle and had two
boosters booster rockets on the side and
a big old orange tank in the middle
that orange tank
has two tanks within it
one of them holds oxygen the other holds
hydrogen
and the hydrogen tank is twice the size
of the oxygen tank all inside the orange
vessel so you have twice as much
hydrogen as oxygen chuck put them
together what'll that make all by itself
h2o h2o there you have it and you and
to make the water molecules hugely
exothermic so you combine them with
valves and nozzles and and and
and and cavity jet cavities and boom you
have a rocket and so when we go to mars
it's important to know that there might
be water under the surface of mars so
then you extract the water separate the
molecules and now you have ready-made
rocket fuel and by the way there's no
such thing as a free lunch
the energy it takes to break apart the
water molecule
is the energy you get back by having
them come together again
okay so just keep that in mind
there's no no such thing as a free lunch
all right so the point is ever since rob
bert goddard
110 or whenever how many years ago
uh we've been using chemical rockets
chemical fuel for propulsion
and
we haven't been using nuclear we haven't
been using
uh nothing else
and so that's kind of embarrassing it's
like our batteries it's still chemical
batteries it's embarrassing all the
other advances we've made in this world
and we're just kind of stuck on this and
so no it's a problem so the two ways
around that one
you have filling stations in space
where you burn all your fuel
you you run out and you just refill
you can burn a lot of fuel again if you
do that
it will take nine months to get to mars
you get to mars in a few days yeah
excuse me guys can you can you get the
windshield and uh check the oil too
please
[Laughter]
that's a way back machine you just
pulled up right there
no i live in new jersey i live in jersey
that's still georgia's full service
that's right my friend that's not way
back god there's no self-serving in
jersey yeah you can't pump your own gas
if you're living here i forgot about
that wow
we got are we gonna get anywhere with
electric
rockets is that is that ever going to be
a thing we've got electric cars we're
talking about electric planes
yeah well so
it's in a sense your electric cars are
not running on electricity in the in
with in that sense they're running on
batteries right so you plug in the car
to charge a battery which is a storage
device of energy a chemical storage
device and then you
uh run the car based on that so it would
be something different if we could just
plug in the car and plug in your
spaceship and have the long cord that
gets you all the way to mars and back
that would be kind of cool
so for me the future is not any this ion
propulsion where you where you
charge a gas and until the point where
like electrons fly off their atoms you
make an ionized gas you might remember
from your chemistry class and if you let
these these these
ions fly off
in a direct in a direction that you
choose then the ship recoils and goes in
the other direction it's very efficient
they become the propellant they become
the propellant it's very efficient
but it's not good for like fast takeoffs
it's good for a slow readjustment of
your orbit or to send a supply a supply
ship or something where you can wait a
few months before you get there so these
are all challenges what i really want
are wormholes
then just open a wormhole and walk
through come out the other side you're
in mars in 10 minutes that's really what
i'm after and
so i'm i'm leaning very sci-fi in this
moment otherwise we're just kind of
stuck here in the solar system that's
the rick and morty approach by the way
yes exactly
or the the cat the the captain strange
no what's his name doctor strange doctor
strange doctor strange
portal step through close the portal
there you are that's exactly how a
wormhole that you control would operate
sweet there it is all right that's
exciting all right thanks for that
question so who's next all right um
someone a lot of people know but not
everybody
a gentleman by the name of jerry rice
jerry right jerry rice right so i heard
him yep a former wide receiver in the
nfl probably the greatest wide receiver
ever
in the history of american football
three-time super bowl winning player
with the 49ers super bowl mvp and nfl
mvp and of course a hall of famer and
another nfl player with a record
collection of his very very own so uh
this is jerry's thought it's a very
sport specific one but this is what he's
thinking let's try it hey neil jerry
rice here i hope you're doing well and
and i have a question for you why does a
football go further when it has spin
oh
look at that and him relating it to his
own sport i like it
i love it i love it okay
so
so i had to remember that that's even a
true statement right of course he would
know that's true because the boy played
the game so here's the thing if you just
have a blunt object such as a ball that
that it's not sort of an aerodynamic
airfoil like what you'd find on an
airplane it's just a blunt object and
you try to move it through the air the
air has to part
for it to move through it that creates
friction that creates drag and that will
slow down the ball
slows it down okay
not only that if it's just sort of
moving through the air
and then there's a current of air moving
sideways to it that'll just sort of
carry it to the side
okay it'll just sort of move it
by the way in baseball forgive the
cross-pollination of sports here
there is a pitch that will move in
whichever way the breeze blows
and what is that pitch called chuck uh
the baby pits no it's a knuckleball
the knuckleball that is a ball that has
no spin
and when you don't have a spin you are
susceptible to small air currents
that are taking place in the air through
which you move
if you spin an object
a frisbee a baseball a football
you spin stabilize it
okay and
when you do by the way you spin a soccer
ball that's a whole other thing i can
talk about in just a moment but when you
spin a football
you
gyroscopically stabilize it as it moves
through the air it becomes less
responsive to something that would try
to
alter its trajectory and by spinning
it's actually corkscrewing through the
air
reducing the total friction on the ball
itself
so a spinning thrown ball will always go
farther than one that is not
for that
it continues with its its profile
yes it maintains its profile and
the the uh there is no hail mary pass
that was not a perfectly thrown spiral
just just check on that
think about it from jerry rice's point
of view as a receiver he has to know
that this ball is going to be coming in
a certain way so he can set himself up
together a trajectory correct yes so a
very important point excellent point so
when you have a spin stabilized thrown
football the trajectory is more
predictable than with any other kind of
exactly the moving object so he's
running and he's doing the brain
calculation be it active or or
subliminal in either case he is
moving at the rate that his body judges
where he will he and the ball will be at
the same place at the same time and not
only that a little known fact about
the american football is that when you
throw it into the air with the the nose
of the of the ball pointed upwards
as it reaches the peak of its arc the
ball becomes horizontal
and then on its way down the nose dips
so that it is always corkscrewing
directly into the wind which is the
minimum air resistance that it can
receive and in that way the ball goes
straight into the receiver's arms
nose first
it's a beautiful thing to watch
yes
wow that's cool there it is there it is
all right so so give me one more before
we end this second of three segments of
athletes ask neil our next uh uh player
is somebody who um
yeah i uh uh
he's played for the giants
anyway
he's a two-time the giants baseball team
yeah no no no the new yorker no no no no
no no no no
giants are not from the brooklyn dodgers
were from brooklyn right you know the
giants actually played in manhattan
really yeah mm-hmm right now that's
that's why they had to name his team the
new york football giants because there
was there were other giants here exactly
two-time super bowl winner two times
super bowl mvp
uh walter payton nfl man of the year
which i think is the most impressive
thing because he's a good guy he's
actually a good guy four-time pro bowler
uh eli manning has a question for you
of brothers manning yes yes yes the
other manning with just a quick thing
about the walter payton man of the year
walter payton died prematurely if memory
served yeah and devoted a lot of his
off-field time to
um to charitable and and humanitarian
causes so i'm delighted that the nfl has
recognizes the player of the year who
who
does the same so this is
one of the great
acts of recognition
in the sports calendar do you know what
his nickname was neil no what
sweet sweetness
or what i mean walter peyton's page not
eli manning
yeah eli manning's nickname eli
manning's nickname was eli manning
that's that's how boring elon is
what question does he have
hey neil eli manning here uh i was
hoping you could answer this question
for me
during my
professional career i got hit by a lot
of big people some big mass can you
explain the physics of some of those
hits please wow
wow interesting
yeah okay so there are two
laws of the universe that we have never
seen violated ever
one of them is the law of the
conservation of momentum
and the other one is the conservation of
energy we would broaden that to be the
conservation of mass energy but
for football we only need to think about
energy so
when two people collide
what you do is you add up before the
collision how much momentum is there
and how much
energy is there energy of motion kinetic
energy just add it up and then no matter
what happens
after they collide
you have to be able to account for that
momentum and energy
okay
now
momentum is a vector
a vector which means if eli because i
don't think he was a very big
quarterback he might have been 190 200
pounds he's running in one direction and
let's say someone wants to collide with
him in the other direction
who also weighs 190 pounds you have
momentum in one direction
and the exact opposite momentum in the
other direction
those directions cancel
which means the total momentum of this
system is zero
even though two players are moving
so watch what happens after they hit
they're not moving okay
so the momentum successfully canceled
and there they just they just
fall down on the ground they'll stop in
their tracks whatever
now
if the person running after manning has
twice the mass of manning
what's two times 190 380 pounds okay
that person has twice the momentum
if they're going the same speed and
collide
there's more
momentum moving in the direction of the
tackler
than in the direction of eli manning so
what happens is after that collision the
entire system is still moving in the
direction of the tackle
okay which means eli manning's forward
motion got stopped
and got
reversed
for that to happen now
how about the energy of the collision
that has to go somewhere that's why they
have the the these football pads have
you ever donned one of these pads
they're these like plates of plastic on
the shoulders and plates across your
chest so that if you hit it
that energy dissipates
throughout the the the pads so that it
doesn't land in only one spot on your
body
the energy still goes into your body but
not all in one place
so that these are physically fit
muscled men so they can they can
accommodate it but not always in the one
spot where you get tackled so the energy
gets dissipated
and the momentum continues and he ends
up flattened on the ground
so
uh so that's why i've i've reported
dooley that american football is one of
the greatest displays of classical
physics yes that there is in this world
yes they spin stabilized projectiles uh
in an arc following the forces of
gravity and you have
endless examples of momentum and energy
transfer
so and and and if it's uh if it's a
really good hit and they're playing the
eagles then that energy ends up on my
couch where i'm like yes
yes because fletcher cox just flattened
eli manning and uh and i'm celebrating
and hoping that eli gets up so i can see
him getting knocked down again damn
chuck where's this coming from chuck
chuck
you resolved you had problems with every
nfl quarterback that isn't from the
eagles that isn't from the eagles yeah
chuck being a native philadelphian no i
just listen
chuck aren't you from the city of
brotherly love
yeah that just means that they um that
when they take your wallet they go
thanks brother that's uh okay
[Laughter]
all right we gotta take a break we're
gonna come back with more questions
from professional athletes and i think
including lindsey vonn the skier the
olympic skier when star talk sports
edition returns
we're back star talk neil degrasse tyson
here
your personal astrophysicist and it's
sports edition athletes ask me
we're testing this out because with the
athletes out there some of them have
geek underbellies uh chuck gary did you
know this you must have known this some
of them yeah it's yeah we're all cut
from different cloths and it's no
surprise that now some of these guys are
super super like ryan fitzpatrick he's a
pretty smart guy yeah you have to be
smart you just have to be curious i'm
not judging people's smartness yeah i
will judge how curious you are now if
you're not curious you know go back to
the cave because that's right you would
still be if there weren't other curious
people in your species that got us out
of the cave in the first place well
that's because you're a science educator
you say that i'm a comedian and so what
i say is there are some stupid people
out there
okay
i'm sorry
all right
all right so chuck gary give me who's
who's next up here all right um next up
and you said it before the break lindsey
vonn um
we all love lindsey vaughn
we do um for those of you who aren't
familiar with lindsay she is team usa's
alpine skier of all the different uh
events in alpine skiing she's considered
probably one of the greatest skiers of
all time period uh
twice world champion and an olympic gold
medalist that's right um and this is a
question that obviously she feels is
important otherwise she wouldn't have
asked it no let's do it okay
a lot of people i know are super into
astrology and i'm wondering if the
planetary and star alignment has
anything to do with people's behavior
okay that reminds me of a really cool
meme
where the bachelor in australia who by
the way was an astrophysicist in the
last season he's an actual
astrophysicist and the girl walks up and
she goes oh hi
um what do you do and he says oh i'm an
astrophysicist and she goes oh that's so
cool i'm a gemini
did he say next
so so here it is just this in all
fairness
to the idea that the universe affects us
just consider what it was like in the
pre-scientific era there you got your
farm out back
and
when the stars align in a particular way
the crops bloom
right and you say oh my gosh i want to
have a ho yeah hey
in the sun and the moon and the and you
start and by the way all of this stuff
moves around you
all right it rises for you it sets for
you so the notion that we are not only
in the center of all of this motion of
the universe but that the universe cares
for us
it runs deep
and across
culture do you realize the brightest
star in the night sky it's called sirius
it would rise just before the sun
5000 years ago and it happened to do
that
at the time of year when the nile
flooded
enabling the ancient egyptians to
irrigate their lands and their fields
and so you say there it is
this caused the rise of the nile
so you can get a correspondence a a
correlation
but missed the cause and effect of it
and so that's how we went for thousands
of years believing that the universe
actually cares about us and cares about
who you are and your social life and
your financial life
and then we learn no the earth is not in
the middle of it all
we orbit the sun like the other planets
and these constellations
which are
really
really sorry excuses for what they're
pretending to be
all right you connect the dots are you
really drawing a crab
connect the dots are do is there r
really
there's a centaur archer
sagittae really really is that what
we're drawing here
and you're not only going to draw that
you're going to put personality traits
in by the way and the people came up
with this are
sleepless
babylonians romans and greeks right they
got they're not getting any sleep so
they wake up oh i got a story they tell
the story they put it in the sky named
gods after it
and now
now you're gonna say that these the
stories of these sleepless civilizations
have such meaning
that these stars in your night sky which
would look different from any other
angle
somehow
know that you were born
and wants to influence you well
everything you said so far makes perfect
sense to me
i'm just saying that it's a holdover
from a pre-scientific era when we
genuinely thought the earth was in the
middle of the known universe
and
uh that is not the case
no so the answer is no none of this has
any effect on us
at all
including the one oh the the moon
affects the tides
and the tides are made of water so
we're made of water so does it affect us
yeah
okay
so it'll raise tides on your body
by an amount less than
the weight of the pillow that you sleep
with in your bed
you can calculate this it's a trillionth
of that by the way yeah so if you're
worried about gravitational tidal forces
on your head
look for other stuff that's walking
around you first
before you start thinking about the moon
and by the way the tides raised on the
moon are a few feet 10 feet whatever
that's on the entire diameter of the
earth
so we got 8 000 mile diameter of the
and we're getting 10 foot tides
on the on the ants oh look at the tides
they're big no they're tiny what would
raising tides on your skull look like it
would be a trillionth the magnitude
of a pillow that you happen to sleep
with on your head that night well
so all i'm saying is we can calculate
what effects it might have and the
answer is none
so i now quote shakespeare um
the fault dear brutus
lies not in our stars
but in ourselves we got another one out
there um okay so joey brzezinski is a
professional skateboarder he's in the
street skateboarding rather than park
just so as you know cool he's a dude
that is full of tricks he's a four-time
winner of the manny mania which is
obviously a a big deal in skateboarding
and he's co-founder of andale bearings
which is obviously one of his sponsors
as well so uh this this is interesting
because i think this is this is possibly
the hottest of hot topics right now so
listen to his question neil and see what
you think yo what's up neil says the
kova 19 put us all on lockdown the earth
has seemed to really benefit from it i
mean the skies over here in los angeles
are cleaner than they've ever been
so my question to you is how do we
maintain this positive reaction as we
come out of quarantine and open our
cities
damn that's a good question great
question
oh man yeah it's interesting you have
these unintended consequences of other
things that happen in our lives
you know we have we have an attack virus
which targets humans
and so we go on lockdown and then our
air is clear to breathe there are no
contrails because we we
stopped flying
and for a big period there we didn't go
out
and so the air got clean and you could
wow
and so how do we maintain that i don't
know
dude
i don't know
um i think it's what it is it's a as we
say in mathematics
if we don't know how to prove something
but we know that it exists
we call it an existence proof we say i
can't get from here to there but the
there has already been gotten by
whatever other means that remain
mysterious to me so we call that an
existence proof so the fact that we can
do that
is an important sort of revelation the
fact that
so much business then got conducted via
by by video conferencing
um
that we thought maybe you had to be in
person for but yeah actually you didn't
all right
that these are things that i think that
not all of that will entirely reverse
i think there'll be many meetings for
which that will take place and that
means you don't have to travel you know
a lot a lot of what was putting
pollution in the air goes away
when that becomes the solution and if i
can give a geeky
einsteinian response to this
so much of what makes that pollution is
the need to be
at a time
at a place
that coincides when another person
is in that same place at that same time
these are called world lines in
relativity
where are you
and when are you
and for us
pre-covid
to have our world lines meet i would say
chuck i'll meet you for lunch tomorrow
at noon and chuck what's your next
question to me
can we do it at eric repairs restaurant
please since you're paying uh
that's fine but you have to specify
where where i gave you a when and you
had to specify where otherwise we don't
meet
we could be at the same place at
different times
or at the same time at different places
but we have to be at the same time at
the same place in order to meet what
zoom has done
is removed one of those coordinates from
our timeline
now chuck we only have to be at the same
time yeah that sucks because that means
that you're not buying lunch and i'm
eating peanut butter and jelly again
we don't have to be and so so that's the
same place
turned out to be one of the great
consumers of fossil fuels being at the
same place
at the same time
so
i if there's anything that
has stayed with us i think it's going to
be the video call the video conference
call after that
you know there are other ways to reduce
the footprint
but um i don't want another virus to be
the the
the motivator i want it to be other ways
that we can be inventive and creative
about how we acquire and consume
our energy needs it's shown us we can
thank you for that question yeah it's a
great question and as i said it's
probably the hottest of hot topics right
now with everybody's mind and climate
but it shows that actually
even though we were painted into that
corner
there is a way for us to
to deal with or at least try and improve
this way you know our own climate so
whether or not people want to grab this
thistle meal is the way i look at it
whether or not there's enough energy in
in the thinking to grab it and make it
happen right or inventiveness and
creativity and especially in los angeles
where the 405 is in some sections is 12
lanes yeah of dense traffic you're not
going to walk out and say hey everybody
tomorrow no one drives so let's see what
effect that has on the air that that's a
that's going to be a failed experiment
kovid became that
commandment
and then we got to see what effect it
has on the air yeah just the air we
breathe forget the greenhouse gases just
the air you breathe all right that's
that that was the first immediate effect
because you can see and feel that in
your lungs the co2 is invisible to you
so that's a whole other thing by the way
if co2 were colored purple
i bet you we'd have solutions to this
practically overnight
yeah you see this purple gas coming out
of your out of your uh out of your
exhaust pipes well maybe but anyways
we can get a virus that will um
increase scientific literacy and then we
won't have to worry about any of this
yeah or a visible virus and then people
will will will not say i don't need the
virus
right exactly
yeah you know exactly you either take
this vaccine or this thumb continues to
grow out of your forehead that would be
great
okay chuck will write the sci-fi novel
a posable thumb head
so that's all the time we have so this
has been star talk sports edition in a
new
version called athletes ask neil i'm
proud of you guys for soliciting these
questions from these great athletes uh i
feel i'm reminded that like i said
athletes
can often have a geeky underbelly well
i'm glad you said proud of you guys
because you should have said proud of
gary gary
this there's a team there's a team
involved in doing this and the whole
star talk team uh yeah the whole star
tuck team ready to do a whole show
celebrating the team or at least get
some web pages where you can see them
all uh they're working behind the scenes
making us look good and sound good so
anyhow we got to call it quits there
gary always good to have you chuck
all right uh this has been neil degrasse
tyson personal astrophysicist as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you